alexis poulain bonjour
heureux de vous retrouver dans la
matinale de rtl france le gouvernement
promet donc une semaine de souplesse
avant les sens inverse avant les
sanctions avec l'élargissement du pass
sanitaires qu'attendre dans les
établissements et les entreprises
je pense qu'effectivement ce matin ça va
être un peu la pagaille
l'inorganisation beaucoup de question
également on le voit déjà les salariés
des galeries lafayette qui lance un
préavis de grève une grève illimitée
dans la restauration est également
incertain restaurant préféré fermer
puisque leur staff ne souhaitait pas se
faire vacciner vous présentez un pass
sanitaires les syndicats qui commence
aussi à poser des questions parce que là
encore une fois la ministre du travail
rester dans le flou on ne sait pas ce
qui va se passer pour le salarié qui
n'aura pas de passer ni terre salariés
au contact avec le public par exemple
dans les musées il n'est pas possible de
proposer un reclassement personnes face
au public dans les réserves voyeur n'y a
pas assez de travail pour tout le monde
donc on est en train d'entrer dans cette
société où chacun de contrôler tout le
monde sans réel cadre légal puisque tout
ça est fait dans la précipitation sous
un état d'urgence permanent donc je
pense que cette semaine aujourd'hui
particulièrement beaucoup de questions
beaucoup de d'à peu près dans les
entreprises qui vont devoir contrôler
leurs salariés de se passe sanitaire
alors que ce n'était pas le cas
auparavant alors alexis le secteur de la
restauration a connu un mauvais mois
d'août à la rentrée sous passe va-t-elle
condamner les restaurateurs
oui je le disais certains restaurants
vont définitivement fermé où vont fermer
arrêté la saison dès aujourd'hui soit
parce que le personnel manque soit parce
que le personne n'aura pas de passes
sanitaires ils ont été les plus touchées
un des secteurs les plus touchés avec
les fermetures à répétition les
couvre-feux les confinements et puis les
restaurateurs le dise l'arrivée du pass
dans le mois d'août a fait que ce mois
d'août est particulièrement morose alors
que le mois de juillet avaient montré
une reprise de l'activité on voit bien
que pour eux ça va être extrêmement
difficile avec en parallèle la fin du
quoi qu'il en coûte annoncé par bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui ces restaurateurs
vont se retrouver
dans une position difficile avec une
rentrée encore plus difficile un été
extrêmement chaotique et morose pour
beaucoup ce sera également difficile de
devoir de vent pour la suite de
l'activité dans le secteur de la
restauration avec aussi là encore un
problème de recrutement puisque déjà
certains professionnels de la
restauration était parti lors des
premières fermetures a dû pour raisons
sanitaires de confinement et aujourd'hui
on se retrouve avec le même problème
mais parce qu'il va falloir se montrer
son pass sanitaire auprès de l'employeur
est là et à certains qui refusent
également donc on voit bien qu on
continue dans cette absurdistan proposé
par ml mâcon imposé par bompard et
maunel vaqueront lors des conseils de
défense sanitaire sans vraiment prendre
la mesure de l'impact économique de ces
mesures pseudo sanitaires qui sont des
mesures de contrôle alors on en sera 50
millions de vaccinés dans quelques jours
selon gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement l'objectif du gouvernement
est atteint alors est-ce que cela va
pouvoir changer la donne pour le pass
oui alors c'est extrêmement inquiétant
de voir que alors que les indicateurs
sont positifs
on voit que le pic épidémique est en
train de passer les hôpitaux ne sont pas
saturés avec le delta les français se
vaccine massivement 50 millions qui
reçoivent la première injection
gabriella talent sûr félicité donc on
pourrait voir que le pass and iter
devrait s'évaporer assez rapidement mais
il n'en est rien on voit bien que le
gouvernement continue de mettre des
petits cailloux vers la voie du contrôle
social permanent avec le même
porte-parole qui disait que se
passe-t-il iter pourra être renouvelée
ainsi l'euphorie généralisée ministre de
la santé au delà du 15 novembre donc on
est déjà en train de lancer à passer ni
terra vit quasiment et l'autre question
qui là aussi peu inquiété c'est s'il ya
autant de français vaccinés normalement
tout devrait aller bien et bien non
gabriella talent n'exclut pas le fait
que la vaccination devienne obligatoire
dans les prochains mois donc on voit
bien qu'il ya une course en avant vers
ces mesures de contrôle social vers bien
sûr là la vaccination pour tous et des
douze ans voire même avant
alors que aujourd'hui on a l'impression
que le pic épidémique dans de nombreuses
régions françaises encore une fois un
certain régions sont plus touchées que
d'autres est derrière nous or ces
mesures s'installe comme si elle était
là pour durer et ça il n'y a aucune
prise de conscience de la part de la
classe politique certains syndicats
commencent à taper du poing sur la table
expliquant qu'il y aura des journées de
mobilisation c'est le cas de la cgt les
syndicats professionnels de la
restauration et autres demande aussi
davantage d'informations pour pouvoir
discuter et bien sûr des milliers de
français qui sont dans la rue chaque
week-end contre le pass sanitaires et
des leaders politiques comme jean luc
mélenchon qui lors des universités d'été
de la france insoumise a dit qu'il était
de se positionner contre le pass
sanitaires c'est le cas également de
ferran philippe haut et d'autre donc on
voit bien que le débat continue et je
crois que
l'exécutif aimerait que ce débat soit
comme le pic épidémique derrière nous
pour imposer ce pass sanitaires aux
français et ça sur une durée très longue
merci beaucoup alexis poulain un édito à
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux on
retrouve lundi prochain bien évidemment
dans la matinale sur rtl france